Yesterday morning we discussed
the sub-chapter that the author
takes us to
and which we arrived at
which is the sub-chapter regarding afa
al-lihya.
Growing the beard.
And
he mentioned some arguments, some of
them compelling, others
not so much.
However,
he does mention the consensus
of the four madhahib
and of Zahiriyyah
and that is that it is obligatory for a
man to grow his beard
and
haram to shave it off completely.
However,
the scholars differ greatly on
what is considered growing the beard,
what is considered
the parameters of the beard. Where does
the beard start and where does it end,
etc.
And
to begin with,
the scholarship of Islam
is almost to consensus, almost to ijma
that it is permissible
to
keep the beard.
Keep the beard meaning to groom it,
right?
To
cut it, to groom it, to
trim whatever is you know,
growing out of control in order that it
be
looking it is kept properly.
However, the parameters of the beard
is something that is referred
to the
Arabic language.
Right? Because
when when the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam says
when he says
grow the beard and trim the mustache,
both of these terms are terms that
he understands
that the companions are going to
understand in their Arabic native tongue
of Arabic. Right? In their native tongue
of Arabic.
And so what exactly are the parameters
of a beard in the Arabic language? The
word lihya or lahya is taken from
al-laha, which is the jaw.
This lower jaw, this is referred to as
a a laha and what grows on it is a
lihya. Right?
And
it is what grows on the jaw
and the chin. This is called the beard.
Now, the cheeks
are considered part of that,
not because they're part of the jaw, but
because they make up a part of what they
would naturally consider to be part of
the beard. right?
This part here
that is what we would refer to in
English as a soul patch, right?
This is not part of the beard. This is
called al-anfaqa.
And this anfaqa is not part of the
beard. It has the same ruling in the
correct opinion as the mustache. So,
what is below the lower lip and above
the upper lip, all of these have the
ruling of the mustache. We can trim it,
we can shave it, we can cut it down, we
can grow it out, but keep it trimmed to
where it is not going above the lip or
below the lip.
And as for the beard, underneath
underneath here,
whatever is growing on the neck and the
throat, this is not part of the beard.
That is an issue of consensus. All of
the scholars agree on that. And then a
person may trim that if he wishes or
leave it if he wishes.
And so, the beard becomes this area
here,
right? And including the chin. This is
This is what is called the beard. Now,
how long does a person need to grow the
beard?
Do they have to grow it to their chest?
When we look at the Prophet
alayhi wasallam's descriptions,
his description is that his beard filled
his chest. Alayhi salat